[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JACK HARTE: Thank
you very much, Katia,
and thank you Natalia for
the invitation to come along
and share some ideas with
you young people of Google.
It's a great
privilege to be here.
I have been around a long time.
I've written a lot of
things as Katia said.
I actually wrote text books.
I did that for the
money by the way.
But there's another Google
fact that I don't usually
put on my CV either since that's
I started out writing poetry,
but I gave it up.
And then when people--
then afterwards-- after
years would ask me
like I'd love to see some
of your poetry, and I said,
no, you can't see it.
So I've been writing prose--
short stories, novels,
plays, you name it.
And I want-- this
is my latest book,
and a lifetime of
experience has gone into it
even though it didn't take
a lifetime to write it.
But the first story
in it is-- well,
one of the first
stories I ever wrote--
and I think it was probably
around '69 when I wrote it.
It was published I think
in '70 or thereabout.
So that's a long time ago.
And who did it and this
is the first story.
The other ones were
written recently
but the ideas that
are in the book
have evolved through a lifetime
of thinking, working, et
cetera.
So I'll give you a
short talk first,
and then I'll read
one of the stories.
And then if you have
questions on that,
you can put them to me.
So I want to concentrate on
organization and institution
because these are two ideas
that I've been playing around
with and trying to
come to terms with them
to analyze for a while
now and very much so
in this particular group.
To me, the most important potent
word in the English language
is organize.
Once upon a time,
it was the slogan,
the call to action of
the political left.
But for political or
social action of any kind,
it was also the first challenge.
There was little point in
mourning or complaining.
If you wanted to change
the way things worked on,
you had to organize.
It meant getting together
like-minded people who
felt strongly about some issue,
strongly enough to dedicate
time and energy to the cause.
It is self-evident
that this is how
improvement in the
human condition
has been affected since humans
began to live in communities.
Organize, go beyond the
individual, families,
extended families,
tribes, political groups,
religious communities, nations,
states, international bodies.
I've been around a long time
and have done more organizing
than most.
The world is more organized now
than it has ever been before.
So am I happy?
Well, no, I'm not happy.
I am now extremely conscious
of a negative outcome
of organization, a phenomenon
that I recognize as a hindrance
to further progress.
I call this institution.
The opposition of
organization and institution
needs to be understood
and addressed.
Let's take it from
first principles.
A group of people come
together to achieve something,
they recruit supporters, garners
our resources, become powerful.
Say they achieve their
aim and due cause.
So what do they do then?
Fold their tents and
go home, disband,
dispose of the assets
in an appropriate way?
Not likely.
Now you have an
organization that
has power, resources,
and people in charge who
like being in charge.
Even though they have achieved
the purpose they set out
to achieve or have abandoned
it as the case may be,
they continue operating,
inventing new purposes
but with one
overriding purpose--
self-perpetuation.
This transition I define
as going from organization
to institution.
An institution is
an organization that
has passed its use by date.
Most political parties are
probably good examples of this.
Because the purpose
of the institution
now is to serve those in charge
rather than the original cause,
it adopts a very
different outlook.
The emphasis is on
unquestioning loyalty
to the leadership
to the institution.
Critical thinking
is discouraged.
Dissent is akin to treachery.
So the organization in
becoming an institution
is an impediment
to progress rather
than an agent of progress.
We see today that
the state, which
should be the absolute
manifestation of democracy,
has been turned
into an institution.
And within this we see
institutionalized behavior
everywhere.
It is particularly
evident in the response
when citizens are abused,
whether by the civil service,
the police, the health
service, wherever--
circle the wagons, admit
nothing, don't apologize,
stand by your
colleagues, the state
is merely a service
provider and the citizen
merely a client, just a
client, and not a member
of the community of
which the state is
the physical manifestation.
My book, "Rehabilitating
the Serpent,"
tries to analyze and
understand and come to terms
with this phenomenon,
the organization becoming
institutionalized,
becoming a barrier
to the achievement of the
very goal that inspired
the original organizers.
I've taken the area of
religion to examine and analyze
because one would expect that
this would be the last place
where the institution
would take precedence
over the central
spiritual mission.
But we know from
bitter experience
that the preservation of the
institution, even preservation
from embarrassment, is
the central concern.
But I want to emphasize
that what I illustrate
in relation to religion
holds good for all areas
of human activity.
I picked religion
because it sets out
with the loftiest ambitions
and falls to the lowest depths.
You may be wondering
what would he
know about organizations
and institutions,
a writer who has probably spent
his life isolated in an attic
room.
So I'll tell you a little
bit about my background.
I was born in a remote
corner of County Sligo, where
until then life changed
little for generations.
My father was a blacksmith
with nine children to support.
When tractors were placed
horses on the farms,
his trade and skills
became redundant.
And like so many
more, our family
became economic migrants.
Similar families went
to England, America,
or other English-speaking
countries,
but we just traveled to
the Midlands of Ireland,
where Bord na Mona
was developing
an industry around the
harvesting of peat for fuel.
During the summer, there
was even work for children,
footing or harvesting turf.
And this was where I earned
my first pay packets.
But within a few
years, the company
had developed machines
to do this job,
and our manual skills
were redundant.
I came to Dublin
with a scholarship
to go to university, but
the money was not adequate.
And instead, I worked at
different jobs including
time in a laboratory, five
years in the civil service,
et cetera.
But I did manage
to pick up a degree
by entering examinations.
Then I went teaching and
ended my employed life
as a school principal,
so I probably
have some experience
at organizing.
I was always leftest
by inclination,
and while I was a
teacher, I was active
in the Teachers'
Union of Ireland,
serving as chairman
of the County Dublin
branch for two years.
Alongside all this, of
course, I was writing.
I published poems when I was
still in secondary school
then turned to short stories
in later years to novels
and plays.
Dublin was renowned as
a literary city always.
So when I arrived
here in the '60s,
I was expecting to find a
vibrant community of writers,
lots of literary events,
and an atmosphere
nurturing and inspiring
to young writers.
Alas, I was disappointed.
The only literary
institutions were
the so-called literary poems.
And these were people
by small cliques
that jealously guarded
their membership
and thus field of influence.
There was no welcome for
working-class young men
or women.
I never found any of the cliques
particularly attractive anyway,
so with other similarly-minded
people of my own generation,
we began to do things
in an alternative way,
publishing our own
literary magazines,
organizing our own pub readings.
One such series of readings
with music ran for a full year
every night--
every Tuesday night in 1975.
Then we published
books, mostly poetry.
It was difficult, but we
had reasonable success
and we were making inroads
into the literary scene
in our own way.
The more I got to
know writers, the more
I realized that each one was
trapped in a personal world
and that they found it
difficult to make common cause
with others similarly trapped.
The very nature of writing tends
to generate this phenomenon.
It is largely a solitary
activity, extremely
personal like giving birth.
And when the work is
delivered, it is like a child
in which the author has invested
his ambitions and dreams
and personality and which he now
jealously oversees with anxiety
and with partisan devotion.
As a trade unionist, I
could see that writers
were ideal for exploitation,
divide and rule.
So they were already divided.
So it was only too
easy to exploit them,
and exploited they were.
Often they were not
paid for their work.
They surrendered
their rights in a loop
to publishers with little
reward without even
considering the consequences.
And the state had no
qualms about marketing
the country as a
tourist destination
on the back of all the writers
who brought distinction to it.
At the same time, the
state expected writers
to be humbly grateful if they
threw a few crumbs to them
by way of so-called
funding for the arts.
I could see all of
this and could not
understand how writers had some
of self-respect as a profession
that they let this happen.
There was almost
no infrastructure
for representing writers or
for addressing their issues
at the time.
Writing was still regarded
as the privileged occupation
of a privileged few.
I remember in the early
80s, Christina Murphy
ran a groundbreaking series
of educational articles
in "Irish Times"
advising students
on their career options.
While every possible career
was covered and many impossible
ones, writing was not
given so much as a mention
apart from journalism.
An activity that generated
countless millions of Euro
for the economy was not
considered a profession.
In 1983, I was appointed
to a position as principal
of a vocational school in
Lucan to become Lucan Community
College four years later.
This opened up some
opportunities for me.
Up until then, there were no
workshops for aspiring writers
as we know them now.
So on one night a
week in my school,
I mounted a program
of workshops to cater
for a whole range of genres--
fiction, poetry, drama--
and in two languages.
I employed established
writers to conduct
these workshops and so
put money in their pockets
however little.
The 80s where a time
of high unemployment,
immigration, cutbacks,
austerity of every kind.
The government brought in the
first community employment
scheme in order to take
people off the Live Register.
Schools were included among
the bodies who could employ
such people under the scheme.
So I applied to employ personnel
including two writers, one
to be a writer in
residence in the school,
the other to do research for me
on the possibilities of writing
as a feasible profession.
It was approved, and for
the first time in Ireland,
we had someone recognized
as being employed
as a professional writer.
The first writer in
residence was not
in any of the universities.
It was in Lucan
Vocational School.
With the man who was
employed as a secretary,
I began to assemble the names
and addresses of as many
writers as I could identify.
By the summer of 1986,
we had about 100 names
and addresses of the
most prominent writers
in the country.
This was a greater feat and
you people might realize.
It was before personal
computers, before the internet,
before Google.
What one could do in a few hours
today with access to Google
took us several months.
Then to contact them, I had to
duplicate a circular explaining
what I was aiming
to do and inviting
them to join the trade union,
the Irish Writers' Union.
We sent out the circulars
in a single crunch
because I was afraid that
if I did it piecemeal,
one clique might associate
the union with another clique,
decide that they would
never join an organization
that the others were in.
So I was absolutely relieved and
delighted when almost everyone
immediately joined up.
The organization was clearly
something whose time had come.
Over the autumn of 1986,
I had a series of meetings
so that we had a fully
established trade union
by the 1st of January 1987.
We immediately began to
work on the issues that
had been festering for
generations like writers'
contract, payments for
appearances at festivals,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Even censorship raised
its head that year,
and we had to deliver
our coup de gras.
During that year, 1987,
the general election
put Fianna Fail into office with
Charles Haughey as Taoiseach.
Haughey had a genuine
interest in the arts
and kept the arts portfolio
in his own department,
appointing the writer Anthony
Cronin as his advisor.
As it happened, Anthony
Cronin had joined
the Irish Writers' Union.
After a couple of
weeks when they
had judged that they had
settled into their seats,
I phoned Anthony Cronin.
His immediate
response was, Jack,
I know what you're looking for--
money.
But the word is
here that there is
money for absolutely nothing.
I replied, no, Tony.
I'm not looking
for money, but I've
no idea I want to run past you.
You're sure you won't
be looking for money?
I won't.
So he met me, and I
explained in earlier times,
the government had bought
up many old Georgian houses
in the central Dublin as offices
for an expanding civil service.
Now during the 80s
recession, the civil service
was shrinking again.
Many of the buildings
have been vacated,
and the state could not afford
even the cost of their upkeep.
Neither could they sell them
because no one wanted to buy.
I want one of those buildings
for a writer center.
I gave them an outline of
how such a center could
be what a good facility is--
a base for organizations,
a venue for events,
a drop in center for
writers, an information hub,
a facility for workshops and
professional development.
It took five maybe 10 minutes,
and then he turned to me.
He said, you know,
that's a great idea.
Leave it with me.
I'll see what I can do.
Within two weeks,
he phoned me back.
You're on, he said.
I got approval for that idea.
Later that same
year, the government
launched the national lottery.
I submitted a case for funding
for the Irish Writers Centre
and received a grant of 100,000
pounds, a building and a grant.
It was a start.
Of course, we ended up
in 19 Parnell Square,
but that's a long story.
We'll be here until tomorrow if
we went through all the twists
and turns of the story.
Meanwhile, the work of the
union had to be kept under way.
Negotiations with other
literary organizations
led to the playwrights
and translators
participating in the
proposed new writer center.
Negotiations with publishers--
the publishers organization
set in motion a project to
establish a copyright agency.
By the time the Writers'
Centre opened in 1991,
we had one of the best organized
literary sectors in Europe,
having started out four
years earlier with the worst.
The key to our success
lay in organization.
I've always been conscious of
the way organizations become--
can become fossilized
and the consequent need
for turnover of personnel.
Originally, I had
hoped to achieve
all I set out to achieve in
two years and then bow out.
But it took me five years.
Then I retired
totally from the scene
and left it to others
to continue the work
and make their own unique
contribution without having me
looking over their shoulders.
But in 2009, I was thrust
back in the midst of it again.
The first cutbacks
of the new recession
hit the arts community
with vicious intent.
And the grant to the Writers'
Centre was withdrawn entirely.
Up until then, the
Writers' Centre
had been receiving
a generous grant.
However, it was the
assessment of the Arts Council
that it was not delivering the
value of our money in terms
of services to writers.
I think any fair minded
observer at the time
would not have contested
that assessment.
Over some years, the center
had become complacent
and eventually become what
I call an institution.
The original drive to
serve the writing community
had been lost,
and now the center
served nearly the interests
of the people involved.
But they felt secure.
After all, this was the
Irish Writers' Centre,
too important to be
dumped, but dumped it was.
The staff were made redundant.
Most of the board fled less they
be contaminated by association
with this failed entity.
Only the binding remained and
three brave board members.
It was clear that the Arts
Council had ruthlessly decided
that the center would close.
The stalwart three
invited me to re-join,
and four made a quorum
for business purposes.
We stabilized our relations with
the bank and other stakeholders
maintaining confidence that we
could survive despite the odds.
Then the debates started as to
how the establishment advisors
who came along claims that we
could survive only if the Arts
Council restored the grant.
I proposed that we had to
start from the beginning
again, turn the board into
an executive committee,
and recruit people who
were prepared to contribute
some time and work.
We had to organize.
This horrified the
establishment advisors
who clarified that the official
guidelines of the Arts Council
demanded boards to
govern, not to be
involved in the running
of the body in question.
But we had nothing to govern.
My three colleagues had just
a short tenure on the board,
so I took over as chairman.
There was an atmosphere of
doom in the country that year
because of the recession.
There were no jobs
for the generation
of graduates who left college.
I felt that some of
these young people
would prefer to be working
for nothing than hanging
around Starbucks.
So I recruited a
team of volunteers
to unpaid but full-time
jobs running the Centre.
The success of the project
is manifest in the fact
that the Writers'
Centre not only survived
but has been
thriving ever since,
embarking on new areas
of activity all the time.
It is not just a place.
It is a vibrant organization.
Having served my four years
this time on the board,
I stood back again in 2012.
As I mentioned, my book
"Rehabilitating the Serpent"
tackles this phenomenon
of organizations becoming
institutions often
with values that
are in direct contravention
of those of the originators.
And it is probably most evident
in the case of religion.
All religions begin in
an imaginative effort
to interpret this very
confusing existence of ours
and to suggest ways in
which life can be improved.
But as soon as an
idea gains traction--
[COUGHS]-- sorry.
As soon as an idea gains
traction, as soon as
an organization gains
ground, certain people
take over all of the time.
They see the
opportunity of gaining
power over other people,
manipulating and exploiting
them for their own ends.
They take control
of the organization
and turn it into an institution
with a central purpose
self-perpetuation, self-serving.
It happens in most revolutions.
It happened to Marxism as well
as to the major religions.
When I was growing
up, the expectation
was that in the
scientific age, religions
would become less
influential, would
be relegated to private
practice in a secular world.
No one would have anticipated
that the inherent attractions
of religion would still
be used as instruments
of hate and murder by power
mongers in the 21st century.
I am a writer, a storyteller .
And when I have something
important to say
or an insight I
want to communicate,
I must do it through story.
And so I want to read you a
story from "Rehabilitating
the Serpent" in which I oppose
the end point of religion
with its starting
point in the hope
that people will recognize
that institutional--
institutionalizing religion
is another travesty
and destroys the very thing
it is meant to nurture.
And it's called
"The Silent One."
Wrong book.
Important that the
page is marked.
So this called the silent one.
"All day they have been
streaming into my wilderness,
assaulting my peace with their
noise and their questions.
I bolted my door
and refused entry
to the clamouring hordes
with their waving microphones
and their sparking cameras.
When the mayor of my local
town appeared at the window,
I relented and opened
the door momentarily
to let him slip through.
I visited the town once a
month or so to barter goods,
so I was familiar with him.
I had always done
my best to sustain
a non-hostile relationship
with the townspeople.
The mayor was almost breathless.
He explained that The Silent One
had been captured and summarily
executed.
During his brief
interrogation, he
had remained true to his
name and said nothing.
Then as they raised
their guns, he
said, ask Johnny to tell you
what happened in the camp.
Johnny is not my real name.
It is a label of convenience
of the global language,
a word that is provided
anonymity but The Silent One--
let us call him Peter
in the global language--
would have given my name
in our native language.
Otherwise, they would
never have identified me,
or it would have
taken them longer
than a week to track me down.
Anyway, Peter would
hardly have known
the name I had adopted
in the global language.
The Silent One, a name
that has transmitted
fear across much of the world.
In our holy wars, he was
the absolute holy warrior.
He slaughtered and slaughtered
and slaughtered, but never
once did he proclaim his faith.
Never once did he,
like the others,
offer up his deeds
to the god he served.
Hence his name The Silent One.
They did not understand him, so
they feared him all the more.
No wonder they dispatched
him with such urgency.
It might appear like a label
of convenience concocted
by the media to give immediate
identification and concrete
form to the shadowy turn
he represented for them
and that they loathed to
embellish for their audience.
But he had always
been The Silent One.
The mayor explained that
the media were pouring
in from all around the world.
They were prepared to pay any
fees I quoted for my story.
A stage was being assembled
right outside my home,
especially from my interview.
It will be ready per 9:00.
That was prime time for
broadcasting a news story.
And the sun would be
gone down, so the stage
would look splendid
on the lights.
Everything would be crisp and
clear for the watching world.
And he had assured the media
people of my adequate command
of the global language.
That was more or
less what he said,
and I let him slip out again.
He had to get ready.
No doubt he would dress
in his finest, hoping
for an appearance on the
stage at 9, a prelude
to break through into
major league politics.
All day long, the big
trucks kept arriving,
their satellite dishes posturing
self-importantly over the cams.
Other trucks brought tons
of scaffolding and lights
and electricity generators.
They were assembling the
stage at an incredible rate,
and I had to marvel at their
arrogance, their presumption,
their unquestioning
sense of entitlement.
What happened in the camp?
How long ago was it?
20 years, more?
But it felt like 200 years ago.
It seemed as if it had happened
to others in another world
or in a particularly
nasty nightmare.
The passage of time had
not dulled the memory
but had petrified
the experience.
It lodged in the soul
like a granite sculpture,
precise in every
detail, immutable.
Yet I no longer engaged with
it in a condition of trauma.
We were children then,
confined to the camp.
Our parents were dead or
missing in the latest outbreak
of the holy wars.
Peter was of course referring
to what happened to Lucy.
Lucy was not her name
in our native language
but the name the global language
that best represents her for me
because her image
always evokes light.
She radiated light,
attracted light.
She simply was light.
She was a little older
than me, not much older,
perhaps a year or two.
Peter was a year or
two younger again.
That is an age gap
among children.
And we looked up to her as
if she were already an adult.
To me, she was the
most beautiful creature
in the world.
One day we were gathered
in a corner of the compound
where the barbed wire fence
segregated our beaten earth
with a pastured
countryside beyond.
We were particularly
downcast in spirit,
and one little girl
complained how can God
let so many bad things happen.
Similar thoughts had
no doubt wondered
to the mind of the
rest of us, but we
were wary of articulating them.
So we deflected the
question towards Lucy,
who seemed to have read all
the books in the library
before they burned it down.
There was only one
explanation, said Lucy.
God is dead.
They've kill God.
Every one of us was shocked
and even more downcast
at this news.
If God was dead, then
we had every reason
to believe Lucy, who then
would come to rescue us.
She must have seen the
despair in our faces
because she immediately
lifted her voice.
Listen, she said, and our
heads bunched into a huddle
with hers.
I read that there was
a people somewhere
who believe that God sang
the word into existence.
Isn't it lovely to think that?
Imagine God waking
up one morning
in good humor beginning to hum.
As he hums, he creates the air,
and there is a fresh breeze
to cool his face.
So he hums louder
and creates the sea.
The wind and the sea began
to play with one another,
and God is so happy that he
hums the land into existence
and gives them the
beach to play on.
At this stage, God is excited,
and he breaks into song.
He sings the sun and the
moon and the stars into life.
His song rises, and he
creates the thunder clouds
and the rain.
His voice softens,
and he creates
the flowers and the insects,
the birds and the animals.
By the time he takes
a rest, we-- he
finds that he has
created a whole world.
Sitting back,
admiring his creation,
he thinks that it would
be good to have creatures
who would appreciate how
wonderful this world is
that he had created.
So one final time, he sang and
wrote human beings into life.
He showed them his
beautiful creation
and asked them to mind it for
him to sustain it by singing.
That is a lovely god, said
one of the younger children.
And now they have killed him.
Lucy was quick to detect
the new surge despondency.
Yes, they have, she said.
But what if we can sing
God back to life the way
he sang the word into existence?
What if there is a little
spark of him left somewhere,
and we can fan it to
life with our voices?
How can we do such a thing.
We're not very good singer.
We do not have any songs.
We can do our best, said Lucy.
And we do have songs.
She started humming one of our
skipping rhymes then twisted
the words cleverly to mean
that she was bringing God back
to life, followed by a litany
of beautiful names for the god
she was resuscitating.
All of this was in
our native language,
of course, so there's
no point in my
trying to recall the words.
But every one knows street
rhymes, even those anemic ones
in the global language.
We all joined in, skipping
to this incantation,
and it lifted our spirits.
Then Lucy took another
line used for street game.
Again, it was more
difficult to play
on the caked earth of
the camp as it involved
hopping on one foot by
kicking a storm to a target
spot with that standing foot.
This rhyme she
shaped into a prayer
that the reborn God would come
and rescue us and reunite us
with our families.
Every day, Lucy had
adapted another line
for the purpose of
singing God back to life.
We rapidly learned each
rhyme and chanted it
with enthusiasm and a growing
confidence in our endeavor.
Then one day, a man was
passing and paused to listen.
Peter was the
nearest to him, so he
asked what the curious lines
were that we were chanting.
Peter enthusiastically
replied that God was dead
but that we were going
to sing him back to life.
The man inquired
whose idea that was,
and Peter proudly
declared that Lucy
had composed the songs for us.
The man, like all
the men in the camp,
gloried in being a fighter
for the cause of religion.
He was clearly horrified
by what he heard.
He grabbed Lucy by her long
hair and dragged her with him,
cursing her with words
like whore and slut.
I followed at a distance.
He dragged her into a
house of one of the elders.
Within a short time, I
could see men arriving
and understood that it was a
hastily assembled tribunal.
When they were all inside, I
went to the door and listened.
They were accusing
her of blasphemy,
of being an agent of the
Devil and calling her
all sorts of nasty names.
All of them agreed
that this illustrated
the mistake of
teaching girls to read
and allowing them
access to books.
They lorded the wisdom of
burning down the library,
and they condemned her to be
burned to death in the square
the next morning.
I followed wherever
they brought her.
After the sun went
down, they dragged her
to a tent in the quarter where
the fighters were billeted.
Surely they wouldn't do
anything to a child, I thought,
but I feared the worst.
Although still a child,
Lucy was on the threshold
of workwomanhood.
And I remember the
way the men glanced
at her with a mixture of lust
and lording in their eyes.
I heard Lucy screaming
and moaning in pain
and imagined the
unspeakable things
they were doing to
her in the tent.
A queue formed, and the men took
turns going inside as if they
were using the latrine.
After a while, I heard no more
screams or moans from Lucy.
I sat on a low wall
outside the tent.
The fighters ordered
me off several times,
but I didn't budge.
One of them threw a
stone at me, and even
though it hit me hard on the
shoulder, I didn't wince.
Eventually, they left me alone.
I was determined
to stay as close as
possible to Lucy so that she
might sense my presence however
unlikely thought might be.
All night, I kept vigil
when that obscene queue
of holy warriors snaked its
way to the door of the tent.
As soon as the first
ray of sunlight
glinted on the
horizon, they dispersed
as if their deed did not bear
the scrutiny in daylight.
I continued my vigil
until two fighters
emerged dragging Lucy's already
half dead body between them
to the central square
where they chained her
to the granite column.
I sat on the ground in
front of her so battered,
so mutilated, she
was barely conscious.
Just then, I was aware of
someone else at my shoulder
and turned to see Peter.
The expression of
absolute despair,
absolute suffering on his
face was terrible to witness.
I put my arm around his shoulder
to assure him that he was not
responsible for this savagery.
I said something to Lucy
to catch her attention
to alert her to our presence.
But she did not reply but
focused her eyes on me.
I said something else.
She raised her
hand to her mouth,
and with two fingers
miming a scissors,
she indicated that they
had cut out her tongue.
Then she waved her
head to indicate
that we should go lest we
should witness the final horror.
Again, I didn't move,
determined to face whatever
horror they were going to
inflict and to share it
insofar as I could.
When Lucy saw that we
were determined to stay,
she became calm.
She even broke into a smile.
At first I thought it was
at us she was smiling,
then she nodded her
head to direct my gaze.
At the other end of
the square, the traders
were beginning to
set up their stalls.
A van was delivering
milk and bread to a shop.
Children were squatting
in a doorstep.
She nodded again
to show I had not
detected what she was trying
to indicate, then I spotted it.
At the base of an abutment,
squeezing out of a crevice,
was a flower newly blossomed.
I remember that it
was yellow but no more
than a weed, the kind that grows
defiantly on any wasteland.
When she saw that I had
spotted it, she smiled again.
She obviously saw some
significance in it
because she kept
her eyes fixed on it
while the men arrived
with a can of petrol,
doused her, and set her alight.
It was a horrible
sight to witness,
but I did not take my eyes
off Lucy until she was dead.
Insofar as I know,
neither did Peter.
A couple of years later,
an attack on our camp
was imminent, and
we all scattered.
Once I was outside
and on the road,
I kept traveling,
scavenging for survival.
I had traveled a great
distance from the camp when
I came upon this shack obviously
abandoned in an earlier
campaign of the holy wars.
I settled here and
here I am still
in this house in a
forsaken wilderness.
Peter joined a band of
fighters on a random choice
it would appear, and he
became the most feared fighter
of all in the recent
campaigns of the holy war.
He was renowned
as The Silent One.
Unlike the others
who were always
boasting their
religious allegiance,
bragging of their
great deeds beseeching
God to favorite them in battles,
Silent One said nothing.
He just slaughtered as many
of the opposing warriors
as he could.
Now, they have assembled this
magnificent stage right here
in my wilderness.
The world has come to my door.
They expect me to give
voice to The Silent One.
The mayor has arrived,
prancing around like a peacock.
As he obsequiously ushered
me to the bank of microphones
and the battery of cameras,
I am blinded by the lights.
Nevertheless, notice
that the backdrop is
peppered with sponsors' logos.
This is clearly
major entertainment.
The war is the
world's entertainment,
more chilling than
the nightly fictions
they watch because it is real.
They have not come to inquire,
to learn, and to understand.
They have come
merely for the story.
9:00 and they tell me the
world is watching, waiting.
They ask questions, barrage me
with questions, about the camp.
But my mind has wandered
back to the flower
that Lucy watched so intensely
as they doused her with petrol.
Did she see it as a message
from her god, a message
that no matter how rampant was
the ugliness and hatred, beauty
and love would
triumph regardless.
Was that why she was smiling?
I want to go back to my
hut, to close the door,
and to think about this.
So I get up to leave.
They are going frantic
with their questions
and their frustration.
But I'm getting impatient,
too, and annoyed with them.
I took none of their money.
I owed them no explanation,
not as much as a word.
Do they not understand that I,
too, was called The Silent One?
All of us who were children then
were dubbed The Silent Ones."
[APPLAUSE]
KATIA LYSIONAK: Thank you, Jack.
And I think we'll all
need a minute or a second
to absorb that.
I think that's been a
very powerful, emotional,
and a masterful journey
in just a few pages.
And I think we're going
to open our Q&A session.
And should we grab a chair?
Or do you think--
shall we?
So the plan is that I'll
ask a couple of questions.
But please prepare
yours if you have any.
I'll invite you to ask a couple.
And just to transition from the
story that you read out to us.
As I've said, it is--
when I read it myself
first time when
I was preparing for the meeting,
I was surprised how emotional,
how dramatic of a story you
could tell in just a few pages.
Literally you took me on
an emotional roller coaster
in the space of--
I don't know, 3,000
words, 5,000 words at max?
So can you tell
us a bit more why
short story is such
a powerful format,
and why is it so
popular in Ireland?
JACK HARTE: Yeah, I do think
that the short story is a very,
very powerful literary form.
I started out writing
poems, but as I said,
I don't admit to it
anymore and certainly don't
show anybody any poems I wrote.
'Course, once I started
writing short stories,
I realized that the short
story is very, very close
to the poem, that it can be
just as powerful in terms
of emotional intensity.
And it can have the
same kind of impact.
And the fact that
it's narrative I think
allows for greater scope
than the actual poem.
So once I fell in love
with the short story--
I was probably the early 20s--
I never went back and
thought that the short story
was "the" literary form.
I still am very much
enamored with it
and still obviously
write it-- a few poems.
But since-- in recent
years, I have written novels
and plays and things as well.
KATIA LYSIONAK: But
what's your favorite?
Is it a short story still?
JACK HARTE: Probably but
as you say, I don't--
I've--
KATIA LYSIONAK: It's
not a trick question.
I don't mean to.
JACK HARTE: Two novels and a
novella and five or six plays.
And I'm started
on another novel.
So I'm not concentrating on
short stories because it is--
there's a problem
with the short story,
and it's similar to poems that
not many people read them.
So you don't really
have much of a chance
of making an impact
on people if you
write poems or short stories.
People talk a lot of baloney
about poems and poets
when in fact,
nobody reads poetry.
Nobody listens to poets except
very, very tiny following.
It's almost similar
with a short story.
It's a small following,
very dedicated following.
And the problem is that the
short story demands something
of the reader, that the reader
has to respond and invest
some cost in this creative
thing called the story.
So the story is not something
that the writer writes
and the reader
sees, end of story.
It's a kind of--
there's a process
which involves both,
and the reader can become
emotionally involved,
intellectually involved and
can use their own imagination
to develop aspects of
this particular story.
So it's-- it has
tremendous potential,
but because it's demanding, it's
not the kind of thing that you
take up on the news and have
read by the time you get home.
That doesn't really work.
And that's why
everybody in the loos
is listening to
their favorite songs
rather than reading
short stories.
It demands work, and so you
have a small following in them.
KATIA LYSIONAK: I feel
like as Googlers, we
can relate to the
discussion about the short
versus long copy.
Those of you work
in YouTube, you're
probably well aware of that.
So what creative works--
so in literary terms,
that's a conversation
about the short
story versus a novel.
And Jack has mentioned that it's
such a niche group of people
who actually read short story.
So Jack would you be
able to maybe describe
who is your reader?
Do you know?
Is it a woman?
Is it a man?
Is it an older person?
Is it a younger person?
What's a target
audience if I may?
JACK HARTE: Well, as I said,
the short story like the poem
requires somebody who's
particularly dedicated,
somebody who's prepared
to apply their minds
and their imaginations to the
reading of the short story
and the receiving of it.
So it could be old,
young, could be anybody.
I had a wonderful experience
with this particular book.
I-- my plumber in--
a few weeks ago and he's
also a very good friend.
When he's finished
plumbing, we always sit down
and have a coffee and
chat and usually takes
an hour of his time, which
he doesn't charge me for.
But anyway, we were
talking recently,
and he said what are
you doing these days?
Any other books?
And said, ah,
yeah, another book.
It was there, so I
said there you are.
There's a present.
So he took it away and
says I don't read books.
He rang me up about
two weeks later,
and he says-- do you
know what he says?
I never read books.
But I started reading
your book last weekend,
and I couldn't leave it down.
[CHUCKLES]
And he says, I
enjoyed it so much.
And then you started
going through it.
Then he had
literally analyzed it
and knew it from
beginning to end.
Now I would never
have imagined him--
my Turkish audience--
lovely fellow and that was--
it turned out that, yes,
he was a wonderful reader.
And taken back from his
holidays I got a text from him
yesterday, and he sent
me a photograph of trees
and says things reminded
me of your first story
where somewhere--
I forget where in the
world Spain or somewhere--
they had these
ornamental trees where
they put them into a brace to
shape them in different ways.
And my first story
is about people
who take over the country
and convert everybody
into dwarfs because they want--
they think that the dwarf
form is the perfect form.
Anyway.
KATIA LYSIONAK: I encourage
everyone to read that story.
It is in your book,
and I've read it.
And, again, it is powerful,
and because it's so short,
I feel like it's so powerful.
Well, another question.
So we're-- I'm going to ask you
something a bit more personal
and less literature related.
How does a working day
of a writer looks like.
JACK HARTE: You'd have to
ask every individual writer
in the country because
everybody is different.
Some people-- they're
lucky or whatever
and they get up in the morning
and they sit down at their desk
and they work for
four hours and then
have their lunch and
then another four hours
and then they have their
dinner and they relax.
Not many people do that.
Most writers have to
work for their living.
So you'll find that there
are lots of people in Google
who are writers.
So they're working day
as they work in Google
until what time, 9 at night.
[LAUGHING]
And when they go home at
midnight, they start writing,
and between midnight and 2:00
AM, they produce their work.
So that's the two extremes, and
everybody else is in between.
I'm not an organized
kind of person.
I write whenever the pressure is
on me to get something written.
KATIA LYSIONAK: I
think we can all
relate to that, the power
of deadlines does wonders.
Doesn't it?
Which brings me--
that's interesting
that you've mentioned
about our own writers
that we have at Google, and
I'm sure we do, many of those.
I have the following question.
So as I've read
through your bio,
I couldn't help but notice
that before becoming
a full-time writer,
you've worked
so many jobs in your life,
among them including time
in the laboratory,
civil service,
teaching, writing
textbooks obviously.
Many young people these
days feel as if they
were stuck in their day job.
It seems to them that
they would rather
be doing something more
creative like writing a music
or writing a book
or do photography.
But they have to pay
the bills and the loans
and the mortgage
and student loans.
So what would your message
to the young and not so young
people who do not find
passion in everyday job be?
JACK HARTE: Again it would--
every piece of advice
would be targeted
at an individual person.
But broadly speaking, I do
not encourage young writers
to assume that being
a full-time writer
is the answer to everything.
It generally isn't.
I recommend people to have
jobs to experience life,
and then when they have built
up a bank of experience,
they can write.
You can't write out of nothing.
The idea you'd love
finishing university,
go and sitting in a
room all day every day
writing full-time just nonsense.
It's absolute nonsense.
Now it might seem strange
coming from somebody
who started the Irish
Writers' Union, et
cetera, et cetera
trying to establish
writing as a profession.
What I feel is that writing
should be adequately rewarded.
If you write a novel today,
if you get it published,
you might get 2,000 Euro for it.
If you're very lucky,
you might get 5,000.
These high profile
people who get 100,000,
they're as rare as hen's teeth.
There are only a few of them.
So writing is not
adequately rewarded.
Now the cynic will
answer oh, yeah,
but you take it to
the marketplace,
you sell it for what it's worth.
That isn't true.
That isn't true at all.
This country owes an incredible
amount of money to writers.
Look at all the money that James
Joyce brings into this country.
James Joyce, whom this
country, this government,
our government, wouldn't
repatriate his body
when he died.
He died in Zurich.
He's buried in Zurich.
And in one stage, his
family made an approach
to the government to see
if they would bring back
his body the same way
as they brought back
William Buckley Yates.
They wouldn't.
But now James Joyce is
the major money raiser,
so they celebrate Bloomsday
and blah, blah, blah.
So the state is
dependent on writers,
but they have total contempt.
Like when they talk
about arts funding,
they'll say aren't we wonderful.
We spend so much in
funding the arts.
Give me a rest.
It's the arts that are funding
the government, the arts that
are keeping the country afloat.
Don't give me this rubbish
about how generous the state is
in funding the arts.
It isn't.
Now if people were
rewarded for their work,
they might be able
to more easily become
professional writers--
full-time writers eventually.
But as a piece of
advice, I say, look,
you have to pay your
bills as you've said.
You have to pay your bills.
You have to look at
things in a sensible way.
You also have to get experience.
I would say that straight
away to young people.
Get experience.
And build up-- look
on it in two ways.
This is the job you do
in order to earn money.
This is what you
want to finance.
So how much time do
you have to spend
at that job or a job in
order to finance that--
work it out, just
a balance sheet.
And get it as well balanced
as you possibly can.
And then you can work
your way towards spending
more and more time at your
writing, your music, your
whatever you're doing.
KATIA LYSIONAK: I think I
absolutely love that answer.
I would vote for you.
If you were to start a program--
arts funds-- arts fund
state, I'd so vote for that.
And I also feel that
we're running out of time.
We're slightly over schedule.
I've promised I'm going
to take questions.
Let's limited to
one, two questions.
Does anyone have
a burning desire?
Please do ask?
AUDIENCE: Hey, you said you
started the Irish Writers'
Centre as a way of gathering the
community together because it
was quite fragmented.
But even now today,
it is still quite
fragmented with the Writer
Centre, the Smoke Factory,
and Books Upstairs, New Theatre.
They all have good support
networks for new writers,
but they don't seem to
work together or create
that network.
Do you see that landscape
changing at all,
or do you think that's just the
way it's always going to be?
JACK HARTE: No, I think
there's far more coordination
than you imagine.
Yeah, there are all these
outlets now, and that's great.
So say, for example,
open mic sessions,
they one in the Writers' Centre
and they have one in wherever--
half a dozen around the city.
That doesn't mean
they're in competition.
That means they're
just more options
for writers, which is great.
I don't think-- say when I went
back to the Centre in 2009,
there was a fairly
poisonous atmosphere,
and organizations
hated each other.
And one of the first
things that I did was
try to open up conversations
with different organizations.
And we established a kind
of network of organizations,
and we actually went in
and made a presentation
to the [INAUDIBLE] in
[INAUDIBLE] one time.
And so it's not as fragmented
as it would appear.
Obviously, there
will always be groups
and maybe there'll
be an opposition
and they won't like each other.
I don't think it's
quite as competitive I
think it's far more
cooperative than appears.
KATIA LYSIONAK: Thank you.
Thank you for asking a question.
I think we will limit
it to one question.
And I'm really sorry about that.
I have a long list that
I wanted to ask Jack,
but I think we'll have
to do it the next time.
I'd like to close this
session with that quick quote
from the book that we all have.
And I challenge you to find
an answer to the question
that I'm going to pose in
the book or in your life.
So the main character
in the book,
Zaya, teaches his people
to achieve satisfaction
in life, not happiness.
Why not happiness
but satisfaction?
That is the question I'm
going to leave hanging out
there because I think that
our generation sometimes
is overly all about happiness.
Instagram is about happiness.
Our meditation is
about happiness.
And I loved that question
because I can relate to that,
and I hope you can, too.
Thank you for today's session.
Jack, thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]